good morning Millennials apologize for
the delay twice oh so we have the most
premium co-host taylors tracker join me
thanks girl we have never hosted
together no I'm so excited I'm so
excited cuz they're ready and even
sitting in our chairs for three minutes
is because getting here wasn't saying
today it's nightmare its UN week which
now all the toasters no actually
everyone knows that it's you and me cuz
it's all over the news right but most
people don't know that the UN week
really disrupts life in the city
especially if you live like above I
would say 23rd Street yes absolutely
where do you live below earth I'm all
the way in financial district which is
like I know I honestly I never spent any
time there ever and then post divorce I
was like I want to escape everyone and
that's the place to go I know was moved
down there did you yeah and I think
eventually I will just cuz it's like
very quiet and like up and coming and
there's nice restaurants and during the
day it's busy but at night it's quiet so
often it's like the amount of ambulances
I've been hearing recently it's like
tenfold like in the trash just even
garbage alone garbage is the bane of my
existence it's like right now on Second
Avenue because of UN Week like the
garbage might have just given up cuz how
can you even get your truck down there
no and the street is just lined with
trash I don't think I have to walk the
street every day cuz I can't take a cab
because of the traffic but I'd rather
walk than sit in traffic or take the
subway it's just not an option for me
but walking is good I like put on my
backpack with like everything on the e
for the day and they just walk around so
I'm getting my steps in girl move down
there I'm telling you I actually ran
into I was having drinks with my tailor
and we were down on Stone Street which
is really fun and Kyle and Amanda from
summer house walked by and we were with
our friend a mutual friend who's in PR
and so they said hi to her and then they
were like oh hey you talk [ __ ] about us
on your show and I was like ah anyway we
like hung with them all night long and
got drunk but they're our neighbors now
they look down there that's so funny did
you see her ink no this was before the
engagement Oh interesting well that's so
interesting because we did get a
question free about what it's like to
like talk [ __ ] about people or have to
comment on their lives and also
befriends them and we'll get to all the
questions for you in a bit before like
all just the housekeeping news anyways
so once I finally got where I needed to
be then we get pulled over my uber by
state trooper which is just the scariest
it could be the scariest thing in the
world even when you're out driving no
I was sitting in the back like with my
like collared shirt skirt looking like
like such a nerd and technically it was
my fault I did ask my driver to make the
illegal move right um so I was just like
in the back you think I'm sorry
you know there's traffic in the city
didn't let us like get into the lane
that we needed to be in in order for
this exit and I was like there's 12
minutes until the toast like do I get
out and just make a run for it seriously
but I felt bad cuz I put him in this
position I know I know I I was in a cab
one time and so I was mad but the thing
is sometimes they did they mess up right
and you're like you can't do that and
then like you know you're gonna get
screwed over so technically it is their
fault like forgetting the wrong lane or
whatever right but sometimes like and
you ask them to do something illegal and
they don't do it they're like that's
illegal so it's not like I made I forced
him to do it but you know I definitely
like you know it was a split-second
decision like Regina George come into it
right and and also the plea there was a
police car in front of us that did it
first so then I was like oh let's do
that too or otherwise like it's gonna
take me an extra eight minutes plus all
the traffic to get where I need to go
anyways I decided to wait it out because
even if we did get a ticket I feel like
the toasters would have been forgiving
if I had to start late I really just
felt badly like I didn't know if you
were here yet I was late to so and I
also I was glad like I'm just so glad it
was you today that like knows we were
going like has done this a million times
before like can get coffee I suppose if
I had like a first timer god someone I
never met before this is not easy to
find what you know work is though you
know where it is right and then it's
just like muscle memory
but anyway so it's really stressful
state trooper comes back and she was
like I'm gonna let you off the hook like
miracle miracle must not be like quota
time Jota season then we get back on the
road get stopped by the train which goes
so slowly it's like the biggest train
every once in awhile like Claudia and I
get stopped by it and we're never in
such a rush so it's just like funny to
watch how slow it goes so slow so slow
so long and I'm like this is hilarious
but the toasters are forgiving Bunch
I'm sorry we're five minutes late but I
feel like doing a later show sometimes
is better for people on the west coast I
agree I agree and for people on the East
Coast you get to like pretend to work
for even longer and by the time this
show ends like it'll really be lunchtime
that's so true that's like I was
watching how to be single
the other night really like a weird
movie I'm not into it have you seen it
Dakota Jon
and I think I tried it and I just did I
couldn't get into it it's like I'm not a
fan of it I watched like the first 20
minutes again and rebel Wilson and
Dakota Johnson expend the night out
which like does there's a lot of flaws
in movies I think they go out and then
they do all these things before they
have to go to work to look like they
didn't they weren't out all night like
they go to dry bar they steal the makeup
from cooming Dale's like they steal
outfits from like TSA lost luggage or
whatever and then they show up to work
and like the boss walks not use like
you're three hours late and she's like
yeah shine the toes yeah I feel like my
lunch time is it like nine o'clock in
the morning no so today so bad my
schedule is so Wow you what's hang can
you wake up um I wake up now I wake up
at like 6:00
but the nice news too like 6:30 and then
I'm like a fireman like I get dressed so
fast like I like I like I like just like
pull my clothes on like one fell swoop
um do you got your clothes the night
before I sometimes do but like if I look
like because it's radio though I don't
necessarily like last night though I was
like going to dinner and I was having a
cocktail and so like I was like like who
and then I was gonna cause I was like
[ __ ] I need an outfit so I'm like
getting ready to go to dinner and I was
like trying to pull outfits cuz I was
like if there's no way I can handle this
in the morning
if I hold the night before when like I
have to be on camera oh that's so smart
also sometimes what I'll do is if I'm
going to dinner and like I don't take
pictures or anything I just where to on
the show the next day - I was gonna do
that but I'm so friggin home last night
and I was gonna be like swamp ass so I
just
no you look so cute and profession I
mean I kind of have a matching vibe
going on if like or grit and like the
shoes yeah with with with with with with
the black toe maybe tell granny shoes
grandma vibe meter like I'm just
embracing and it's good stuff well
anyways we have such a fun show for you
guys today and I just actually the
stories you could technically live
without um but I do want to kind of slow
today the news was so but I like so just
like get your pulse on things like I
love having co-host and just seeing how
that like coz cloudy and I pretty much
agree on most things yes you know we do
well we think that like we do all the
same things we like have the same life
experience so like makes sense we'd like
the same house wide etc so it's like fun
like I love when Ben's here because he
is just like totally is he a fan of
Bravo
yeah I love that I love that but
I feel like he also pretend like he's
not like Claudius always like Beverly
Hills Lisa Rinna's such a [ __ ] starter
like that's what he'll say where is my
Zack but not that hers is Zack but Zack
like loves Bravo like true I love that
my tailor doesn't really what what why
am I even bothering being a lesbian just
that it was like a guarantee we would
watch Bravo together no totally and like
when you're watching different TV shows
which is what's happening miss a can die
right now like he was like binging 24
which is apparently like the longest
show known to man it took him like a
month it is and I was just watching like
stupid [ __ ] like insatiable and I don't
what do you think about insatiable I
love um Sarah Colonna who's that she is
the mom she is oh she's debby Ryan's mom
yes and I love her like I was a human
being I don't know I just have her on
the show all the time and so she was on
Chelsea Handler like on the roundtable
okay it's like Heather McDonald's okay
so I put crew I don't know if the yeah
good crew and so I kind of watched
accessor on her Instagram and then I was
like I kind of like love this but I
haven't finished it okay don't finish it
because the first three episodes I
really did enjoy I was like this is like
so campy and funny and and like twisted
and and weird and like i like debbie
ryan giving me like jesse disney channel
vibe and she she's loaded gomez Rosa
just me no she's like a little bit of
everyone it's seven years oh great it's
so weird I feel like she was made at a
Disney Factory where has she been also
she got actually I think she got like a
DUI do I look that good for her yeah she
like did you like she did Disney and
then she like did like turned and now
she's Netflix which i think is a good
home hacker yes
um so yeah the first few episodes are
like good and interesting and it's like
what am i watching but then the last few
are like I don't ever want to wait up
for a second season I know do you won't
watch season 2 I mean I will if I really
am like have run dry of things to watch
but I just didn't like how it ended it
just got really weird yeah it's Giggy
I'm at the point where I'm like this is
getting really weird with like vampire
bites and stuff like yes yes I'm there
I'm there okay and then I watch the
other day on Netflix
Napoli ever after it is so [ __ ] good
is it oh my god I was gonna watch
for a movie on Netflix and then I just
wanted watching trailers for an hour and
that was my movie that's literally what
I do unless I'm going there with a
purpose I just watch trailers I see
what's out there and then I'm like oh
it's time to go up and now I only really
watch like recommendations so if you say
it's good I watch it I really liked it
again I was drunk you see the theme I'm
always drunk so I mean I'm that could
escape my perspective but I liked it and
I liked her honey was her name is sunny
or Sanaa I'm she's from love and
basketball she's the actress who
allegedly bit Beyonce you're lying swear
I mean she was the number one came out I
have to watch yeah and I can't like
think they pretty much nailed down who
it was it was like she was like the only
one who an in memory like was connected
to it but didn't Beyonce say to Tiffany
Haddish this [ __ ] is on drugs yeah so
she's on drugs
I mean well but like drugs she wouldn't
be the first person you know it's what
we've come to expect so whatever I
recommend it um also think about
insatiable is I don't know if it
deserves a second season and it brings
me back to like another grievance I have
those Netflix is the fact that girl boss
did you ever watch it so bad what I
loved it you know well I just loved her
Britt Robertson like I love her I loved
her as an actress and I just thought the
story was like cute some episodes
weren't wearing the hernia it was like
really [ __ ] weird I give up honestly
easily halfway through the first episode
oh my god and isn't it Charlize Theron
she's like the executive producer on it
yes and that girl from pitch perfect Kay
like I don't know some one of the
producers is also on picture so it's
like a good like good like backing
behind it yeah I was Netflix I thought
it was so bad oh my god I thought it was
so cute drugs watching it and in the
last episode of the season was where
like Nasty Gal is really about should I
pop off and become a business not just
like an eBay store and you know I would
have loved season 2
really yeah maybe I'll give it a shot
I'll give it a try I just said what's up
and really she can't like Britt Roberts
and I love her so much I loved for
longest ride is like one of my favorite
movies and oh my god like I've seen it
probably 20 times now and it's on TV a
lot like on
sex movies which by the way have the
most premium movie choices and I always
cry every single time budget I was I
died I literally died I went to a
screening and I brought Taylor with me
and we walked and we were it was like it
was like the first movie we saw together
and it was just like oh so good
hey so good there's so many different
layers it's like there's the art layer
there's like the Scott Eastwood like
just mija Nicholas Sparks they are being
hot layer the bull-riding layer like and
then also the Jewish layer Holocaust
yeah it's like it's so it's like an
onion it's like an ogre
we should recommend that as toast movie
of the week okay someone remind me and
you recommended something it was either
you or Claudia on it was a Netflix like
teen select was it the one with that to
all the boys to all the boys with the
cute asian girl yes oh he's so good and
they're making a sequel they are and I
just yeah and I loved her like I just
loved watching her I loved her style
choices like well she was you she was so
cute when Peter was like you have way
better style than Jenn even though like
while he was still dating Jenn I was
just like that's a man who's in tune and
then I knew that he was the right guy
Jenkins suck a dick anyway there was
another one that was also also a winner
what a gem what did you and it's made so
much better I so fact that they're
dating in real life they are yeah
I'm so so tall and she's so small and
it's it's really cute they're so cute I
love no have you seen Sierra burgesses
loser no mixture grace yes I tried it I
was watching on my phone or on the train
I did not like it you can watch movies
on your like you can visit Michael do
you know how much data I go through my
[ __ ] phone I can't watch stuff on a
small screen like I can't watch a movie
I mean I was desperate I'll do it on my
iPad I need an iPad like I mean I have
one I need a new one yeah the one that's
like like I feel like a loser watching
my phone and my focus is so ugly they
silly me that oh I know your function
whatsoever without further ado 17
minutes later are technically 47 minutes
later the new use to it here are the
fast side stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast okay
first story is really sad and comes on
the tale of us talking about her at
length last week but Marcia Cross
reveals she's recovering from anal
cancer cancer Desperate Housewives
alumna Marcia Cross is on the road to
recovery following a battle with anal
cancer the 56 year old actress posted to
Instagram last week saying she lost her
hair due to cancer and then clarified
she is recovering from the disease quote
so grateful and happy to be alive but
sad that my hair fell out and is about 1
inch long now and looks cray-cray she
wrote anyone else have cashed at hair
loss due to cancer talk to me I feel you
xoxo m cross later wrote she was
recovering from cancer adding that she
was all good now hard journey but I am
healthy and more present and grateful
than ever
Wow that like I love her so much and I'm
so glad that she like she's recovering
now as opposed to hearing the news
initially and then it's like you don't
you don't know so it's like time results
gonna be yeah so I'm glad to hear that
she's doing well and like she seems to
have a positive attitude I know yeah oh
god that's so hard I'm God I mean
there's so many different phases of
having disease like that but I think for
women it really is I mean not to go back
to Napoli ever after but there's kind of
undertones of that like there there's a
scene where she I don't give too much
away but she ends up like at a cancer
group by mistake and anyway but it's
like a woman's physical appearance you
know it it's an important part of being
a woman and so to lose your hair I can't
even imagine how hard this and also like
women have you know double mastectomy
and it's just so sad it just takes such
a toll and so to not lose like your
faith or just your excitement to be a
lie like that is the silver lining yes
you're alive and that's wonderful I know
and you can have like some wake parties
I know right yeah oh my god that reminds
me of like Sex in the City when Samantha
got cancer oh my god so sad that was sad
but again a positive like she just had
such a positive attitude make me like
that yep that me like helps a lot yeah
more so than you would think like when I
was little and I would hear about people
getting cancer it was like it was the
end and I feel like it's like there's
more hope behind it for sure there are
conspiracies that there are cures for
cancer but I'm like they're not giving
them to us because I they want to
continue to make money because I'm
called you is like such a big part of
medicine do you believe that I
I have to not believe it because if it's
true it like we live in a world of
monsters I have another random
conspiracy theory question for you just
personal I don't know if you have any
expertise on the subject but 23andme
apparently there's like conspiracies
that they're like selling your
information and like empty like did a
podcast about it my glitter as he posted
his podcast I was doing my swabs and I
put it in like it's in the box it was
making space and it's ready to go out
but then I realized it was shipping to
North Carolina and I didn't want it to
get like lost with the hurricane and
whatnot so it's still in my apartment I
haven't sent it out yeah but people are
saying don't do it don't send them your
DNA like then they like give it to the
gun back to conspiracy theory I will get
behind do you think have you done it I
have not done it I just really want to
know like what I'm about like makeup you
know I don't know I don't like the
government having any access to myself
like I actually hate that my money's in
a bank I don't believe in banks so what
we put it under the mattress like
literally I would rather have that under
the mattress but I don't you do Bitcoin
oh hell no that's even scarier yes but I
think technically is it's more secure
but it's like wrapping your head around
it is the impossibility my mom used to
always say when I was like a teenager in
life it doesn't make sense then like
some something's askew it doesn't make
sense so something's askew and I'm not
gonna like [ __ ] with my money
no no just what you could get it all out
and then like invest in like diamonds or
something I have to invest or well my
like whatever JPMorgan and like adviser
my manager you know my manager Tom yes
he literally took me to the bank was
like you need to invest your money and I
was like crying the whole time I did not
want to do it what do you want to invest
in well I'm exhausted I don't know I
invest in like um like the safest one
possible it like it grows at a snail's
pace oh it's like a bond or some bond I
said bond
okay cuz I'm like such a wimp I don't
but there's a stock market there's low
risk so it's like low rate like a low
slow rate for profit but then it's also
low risk so I can't handle like I told
the guy that was investing if I lose
like $10,000 I'm gonna like cut your
dick off so he's right let's not do that
bonds are for you Wow what's over me and
like literally old people do you watch
billions I another show I tried and
didn't like really yes
it's polar opposite taste in shows no
it's good it's good because I'm sure
there are other people that don't like
Billy's I just I watch season 1 like
years ago when I was on Delta and then I
caught up literally last week and now
I'm just even more interested in like
stocks and shorting I'm even reporting
like some stock business news on the
shows doing how's it going it's going
really about people yeah well it's nice
for us that to talk about like other
stuff and use different parts of our
brain and then also people are like
there they just feel so informed like
knowing that Amazon and Apple are both
at one trillion I would never know that
what does that even mean there that like
Apple was the first US company to hit a
trillion dollars an Amazon recently just
hit it as well Wow move over Kylie I'm
so mad she's a billionaire I don't wanna
talk about it when it's kind of
cosmetics gonna go public so I can
invest in her her no I believe in her I
don't like Kylie I know I know I know
Claudia and I we I like I know where you
staying because I talked about to
claudia about it but she is like so for
Kylee I'm assuming you are - of course
I'm so not I'd like it makes you mad I
feel like like Kim did all the hard work
like literally on her back and now Kylie
gets people the benefits cuz she's like
Kim Kardashian mini-me yes yes and no I
can understand how you would think that
but Kourtney had the same opportunity
like to reap all the benefits and she
literally is just living off the land
she's invented nothing created nothing
like done nothing original whereas like
Kylie and also then Kylie might've reap
the fruit of Kim's labor but then Kim
did copy what Kylie's doing in terms of
her owned and operated makeup line and I
think Kylie doesn't mind because Kylie
respects and understands what Kim has
done for the family I also just don't
understand though how you can have a
like a lip kick can like literally make
you a billionaire like literally in what
like two years but her lips that were
allegedly from the lip kit she admitted
were lip injections I mean like that I
don't get like in no other world but the
Kardashian world would like that fly
that I ruin abyss right you become
famous for a lips that like aren't even
yours yeah and then people like but I'm
soaking about lip kits even though
they're not it's not from her lip kit
but I think like her struggle with her
like thin lips and initially she did
over line them and that's what
two lip kits and then eventually she did
a more permit a she's not super
permanent solution
haha I think a lot of people relate to
that because also right now like
everyone wants big lips so there are a
lot of thin let people who wanted to do
what Kylie's doing because it works for
her yeah and also like I'm obsessed with
lipstick are your lips your lips are
naturally my lips are natural I'm so
[ __ ] jealous it's rude it's not fair
well I mean if they were I think I don't
know I don't know if I would get
injections I've just heard they're
really painful I actually had a friend
of mine who's like in the makeup
industry and she was like you need to
get lip injections and so I was like
okay like I get Botox whatever I don't
care
and my tailor was like no way do not get
them so I'm like I'm grappling with the
idea why doesn't she want you to get
them he's like hey he's kind of like a
guy and that she doesn't like the idea
of like hot surgery like scares totally
me I like that too I'm like I'm getting
a facelift I'm definitely getting a WIPO
it's not like what she's like can you
just like go to the gym and I'm like no
I could do that too but it wouldn't have
the same effect how does she feel about
Botox she's fine with it just cuz it's
like she knows not to even like it
touch that that's like that's of my
dad's like business he's like mr. Botox
so I'm like I'm gonna Botox I love the
job right and like I feel like initially
people think oh my god is gonna do it
like just don't change how you look and
it's like it's not gonna change it's
just gonna enhance and then I'm stop
giving you dirty looks all the time even
when I'm not trying to that's wise for
me like I literally used to always just
look like this my botox is wearing off I
hope I I know mine too I'm not a good
representation of my dad's work right
now when are you gonna go how often do
you do it I do look every six months
that's when I'm striving points I want
to go back now I'm trying to get my dad
to come to the city so I have to find
him like office space he's in the
optimal she's he's an eye surgeon but
he's really good at Botox so interested
I think about it like an eye surgeon
it's muscles like around the face in the
eye like like an eye surgeon really
should be doing it it's familiar with
those muscles yes so I highly recommend
my dad I'm gonna try to get him to come
to New York then every go he should do
and pop up yeah like it like it like it
toasters Botox party um toe tags toe
dots
I don't know I'm here for it I'll be
there okay okay next up sad kind of
shocking news
Holly Madison's husband Pascal Rotella
files for divorce yeah Hugh Hefner's
ex-girlfriend Holly Madison is getting
divorce
the former Playboy model 38 and her 44
year old husband Pascale Rotella are
calling it quits
four years of marriage ET reported the
former couple had their first child
daughter rainbow Aurora in March 2013
six months later Rotel and Madison got
married at Disneyland they welcomed
their second child a boy named Forrest
in August 2016 I hate them so much right
now
there's like every detail you give I'm
like hate hate hate well did you ever
read her memoir I didn't okay I did so I
feel like really personally victimized
by this news because her whole life was
like such a whirlwind and she really
talked a lot of smack about Hugh and the
playboy house she did she did I forgot
what went down there and I feel like she
didn't even talk the moat like she did
it in the least petty way possible but
it's like so many atrocities were
committed there that even just ripping
off like one layer was just so
informative for us right
and then she dated she was the one that
gave the detail away that like they
would all stand in line to like have sex
with him yeah they was like I'll be like
on a bed in his room and like he would
just like I have a an erection they
would all just like jump atop yeah it
was really creepy like there were some
really lewd details and I think like
that experience I kind of like messed
with her and then she dated Chris angel
I forgot about that yeah and I remember
at the time when they were being I was
like oh that's kind of cute and then
like reading it in her memoir like it
was not cute really yeah it was he's
like a total freak monster I think he
was just like really crazy yeah he's
read the book like four years ago now so
I'm fuzzy on the details but then toward
the end of book she meets her husband
now and like she is a big fixture in
Vegas with her Pete show and then he
runs um
EDC right not the what's that big one in
Vegas the big electric carnival
I think it's EDC I you would know it's
like the big raver so he runs like Oh
black company okay so he does really
well that's white I think their child is
named rainbow and Forrest that's where I
was like I don't like that and they just
seems like and then I would like look at
her and see him they seemed to me like a
match made in heaven cuz like she would
just be like a rave girl and he was her
rave King and together they ruled the
rave girl world
we're telephone for divorce on August
31st 2018 in Las Vegas according to
documents obtained by the blast
Madison was served with divorce papers
September 19th Rotella confirm the news
and a statement on his Instagram that
Madison also shared quote it is with
love in our hearts and a deep respect
for one another that Holly and I had
amicably made the decision to separate
first and foremost we are forever
partners and parents to two beautiful
children and are fully committed to
raising them in an environment filled
with love and positivity quote Holly is
a talented woman and a beautiful soul we
remain the best of friends while
co-parenting and continued to support
one another in our respective passions
and life though it was not a decision we
made hastily or take lightly Holly and I
welcome this next chapter in our
relationship and of every confidence
that the future will bring only the best
for us and our kids we will always be
family thank you all for your continued
love and support mm-hmm that's actually
a lengthy too much statement I testing
too much do you think so well cuz I was
divorced so I know how that goes you've
got to announce it you know and I just
feel like he could have just done that
literal last sentence we are a family
still and basically respect us and leave
us alone
like that's enough you know what I mean
yeah it's like you remember that friend
you were an angel you were so talented
it's like then why you getting divorce
all those things are she writing divorce
Gina from the Real Housewives of Orange
County right exact my best friend we
still have sex I'm still attracted to
him but then why would you break your
family up like it's like a wonderful
relationship the same thing was with um
Channing Tatum and Jenna I mean they
were like we are best friends we love
each other
like he's so awesome I'm so awesome
we're still awesome together it's like
then why are you getting a divorce right
like the so many couples would kill to
have like two out of five of those yeah
it's like we both love our children and
we both respect each other we're best
friends that sounds like a good marriage
stay married like I mean I understand
trying to split Emma kablooie like my
husband and I definitely tried to do
that we tried we did the best we could
but you know it's your it's a breakup
it's not like fun and butterflies and
sunshine and rainbows it's it's a
breakup and it's sad and I feel like to
like pretend like it's anything else is
kind of I don't it's just so phony it's
phony and it's like it insults me
personally you do it's like you really
think that I'm gonna buy this even
though I almost did by the statement
until until you straighten me out thank
God good just sometimes they can be like
really naive
subber news but then on the other hand
like such a conspiracy theorist it's
weird I'm so negative toward celebrities
it's terrible
I'm like such a hater I'm just jealous
definitely also they are soaked like it
is so fake like these canned statement
it's such crap and it's because all
their publicists do it for them right
you just let them do it on their own but
it's like what's the alternative like
putting out a statement he cheated on me
like but there's also the father of your
child I mean I don't know that he
cheated on her anything there has to be
something Shaddai here
Sade I love that I've stole that from
you guys um I think that it's there's a
happy medium between like Disney Land
and Disney World like divorce style and
like where they also got married
telling the dirty truth that's another
reason why I hate them yeah Disney that
like surrounded by Disney freaks my
girlfriend loves dizzy my little sister
and her husband are going to Disney
World for their honeymoon with my mom
and dad and his family right now
like their Disney World like they love
the party world freaks yes but then also
the movies like all thing it is like my
sister's wedding was like two weeks ago
and my speech to her was like she's a
Disney Princess but she really gives
it's not a joke like I love Disney but I
might but like Disney World like going
there doesn't do it for me okay good
tonight like I had when as a kid once
like in the Florida ones and that seems
like enough it's like the worst no it's
like lines attractive bad food germs
kids no alcohol apparently they're
introducing alcohol to the one in
Anaheim now which makes sense cuz like
it's all filled with Bachelor people
anyway everyone loves this Stassi
friggin loves Disney like the Vanderpump
rules people are always there show their
lives there yeah and also Universal like
whenever I'm gonna go out there psyche
and whoa good at Disney I'm like that
I'm not coming I don't want to fly
across the country to Disneyland that is
truly so weird like I guess maybe cuz we
don't have a Disney I guess we could go
to Six Flags technically oh I know you
don't but that's not the same but he
could go to Hershey Park ha ha ha I went
there when I was three and I licked the
wallpaper true story I thought it was
Willy Wonka's chocolate factory that's
really cute my mom is friend
yeah I like to steal them on I don't
know what I'm gonna do like about my
future kids like there definitely are
never stepping foot in a water park like
that's for sure you know amusement parks
I mean I want them to you know to be
normal live a little
right but if they give me like such
anxiety my kids are gonna be
homeschooled because I can't afford a
school in New York I'm gonna school them
they're not gonna go to college they're
gonna either be like electricians or
plumbers or cuz like it's like
construction so they're gonna be useful
doctors of society yeah and they're
gonna work for me that's Beth you've got
it all figured out I'm so ready for kids
what's your curriculum gonna be like
homeschooling like what subjects I can
walk to Bravo I feel that you learn a
lot about like sociology - Bravo 100%
um I'll of long division like a
handwritten long division super useful
because we don't have calculators or
anything like that I love long division
- that's so weird it's the only skill
that I learned that I really apply all
the time and you know what I also use in
everyday life aside from legal jargon
like I always whenever I'm trying to
figure out percentages or like what's
20% of this or uh I always do like blank
over blank equals x over 100 and do that
oh my god 8k gives me I can do that
better than I can trying to figure out
percentages on a calculator I can't do
that that's just you are oh my god x
over 100 has changed my life I'll give
it a shot like my notes have like that
on it like that whole formula if you
know it you know that's really it that's
where the buck ends for me in terms of
learn yeah and then reading I guess
although you can watch it in on TV
anyway or an audiobook yeah exactly you
scratch reading over it and then like
when they're like driving it's like
they're going maps is also a very useful
skill yes something we didn't learn you
should teach them about taxes yes
definitely and then also um how about an
investment course you should sit in
becomes the teacher well this is really
something that needs to be implemented
in schools and I think you've been in
high school because college they have
their own like you know you need to read
the odd
in the Iliad which whatever but in high
school like there should be courses
where here this there are so many
already [ __ ] courses in high school
like like home at calculus right but
they do like some sort of useful step
woodshop class so dumb
so what that's tax class I think yeah
definitely I'm for that
that'll be in my home schooling you can
enroll your children at Taylor's record
calm here wait anyways I hope Holly
writes a second memoir so I can really
make sense of this I don't know I want
to read her first one you should I will
I read it in like a day because it was
like there were I remember when it came
out everyone like some editor reads it
and then writes the 15 things you need
to know and it's like yeah those things
are interesting but it's like what's
between the lines oh yeah
I would survive what does she like and
you know what I've learned that I really
like yeah and she looks like Emily
Maynard which is a win for me
former Bachelorette oh right you don't
talk with the bachelor so much I can't
it's too much of a time commitment sure
I really I I can't it's I'm I'm like
Brava all the way and that's really it
do you watch everything on Bravo pretty
much everything yeah like everything
everything the only thing I haven't
watched is the Savannah southern charm
Savannah although ravenel he's off he's
also them charm now and he's in the
slammer well he made bail twenty
thousand dollars I believe that's it
he's wave rich they should have made up
way more money than that
yeah but it's just all good news like
for Catherine cuz there's no way she
doesn't get full custody I know I know
he's such a piece of [ __ ] also I feel as
though this is unconfirmed but I was
just like reading stuff that made me
believe that southern term Savannah is
no more one of the cast members posted
something that made it seem like it was
very much like a final goodbye and then
in the toasters there was I think it was
from like a fake website but that it was
canned but I said what who would even
report it's not like a huge story right
he's like they never told us wags was
canceled not over it no I want to go
watch what happens I only watched wags
LA and the people that I loved from it
are getting their own reality show now
okay because there are two cousins and
they had like they're just like a
beautiful family and now they're friends
best friends with Kim which I still
don't know how that happened so that'll
fill my eyes me but it's like how do you
just cancel shows and not tell us Royals
I'm so upset about that I literally
watch like we're
Oh oh my god I loved it so much and the
way they ended the last season like made
no sense just notice all your shows get
canceled no like all of my favorite
shows this is a pattern throughout my
life like GCB you ever watch at that was
amazing amazing that's such a sin well
that was a Darren star show which I
didn't realize because when I was doing
getting younger the first time around
like so last year two years ago somehow
it came up and he was like yeah that was
my show and I was like oh because and
who is on here I'm sure right um
Diana yes she was an F so that's why
that was my best
Patricia underrated Kristin Chenoweth
was in it right yes so leslie bibb you
had the girl from the the blonde girl
wasn't it yeah what was she from she
started something terrible show I used
to love um I'm like this popular yep
mm-hmm
another amazing show canceled canceled
ah there was one show on The WB like and
they started when I was really young
um my favorite shows getting canceled
popular at least got to see since I
believe but there was a show called the
help and I believe Megan Fox was in it
and I'm sure she would deny it now you
can't find it anywhere stuff but it was
so good there was a show called like
American sweethearts and it was starring
Kate Bosworth who at the time was like
moved to town so she was like a person
that we socialized with and I remember
wanting the show to fail and it seems
like it did it did I thought but it was
I supposed to be like the next Dawson's
Creek and she was like the next Katie
Holmes well she did pretty well for
herself yeah I know she stuck me with my
very first boyfriend so like I obviously
have like issues with that are you guys
still friends
no I ran into at the Soho House and it
was like so weird because it had been so
long and I was like oh my god hi you and
she what she acted like we had just at
each other five days ago
does that yeah she wasn't rude no
catching up like she was zero excited
but she wasn't also like disgusted she
was just like oh my god hi and I was
like what we have is each other in like
literally 10 years like you have no
excitement in this matter right or like
how
are you how's it have you been it was
really only my interviewed hurt serious
and she was super sweet there's a
picture where she's like has me like in
her nook which made me feel like super
special and she had her husband Michael
polish with her and now she like doesn't
follow me on Instagram and then follows
Our Mutual best friend Chris I think
we're gonna fight over our friend Chris
I think that was that but like a very
subtle one but who's closer with him me
so you win so weird isn't that weird
like a weird anecdote Kate passwords I
know I know
she's like holding grudges she was like
we were in a competition but I was only
invited to the party for the competition
you know like I was like nothing in her
radar meanwhile I was like having like a
silent war with Kate Bosworth in my mind
no it seems like it's in her mind too
and it's like bigger nice to know Kate
Bosworth holds a grudge I don't know
where she keeps them all but they're
there we were talking about former shows
that got cancelled that I love yes every
so every started young with the help
then GCB was another I used to like sign
and start change.org petitions to get it
back like sometimes that works of that
worked with Marvel moved from ABC to CMT
yes it did and now it's over I wouldn't
say that's cancelled at a certain point
like a show has to end
I hope younger goes on for a million
years so I have a job um and that's what
I'm gonna say at least we can agree on
younger oh it's so it's so good how many
seasons really do you think I can go
like I was thinking about this for
realsies the other day well here's the
thing for so long it was like the format
was you know Liza tells one person nice
it tells another person they fight they
make up and then but now it's like
totally shift like the way that this
season ended yes it should the secret
should come out and then the show should
evolve from there as like a kind of like
a new type of show not as a 26 not as it
for later year as a continuation of the
cast buttons like different just like
instead of her from hunting to be 26
like now okay she is 42 everyone knows
she's 42 and this is her life now yeah
like with new struggles and and hurdles
and whatnot and then like also like
watching Kelsi Hilary's character like
you know try to be this young it's like
reverse ageism where she's like young
and like all these older people and she
seriously and but now she has all this
power yep
but also Kelsey is the worst I
love Kelsey oh my god she's the worst
she makes the worst decisions and it's
like what only only you're allowed to
sleep with everyone in the office but
when Liza does it once you can't ever
speak to her again
I guess she caught a bigger fish than
you like I can't and also you're living
with Josh also yeah that's you are in
now the head of a publishing house and
you can't get your own apartment
true story even when she was in even
when she was just an editor and she was
living with in her friend's townhouse
and she got kicked out rightfully so
you've been saving money all these years
she left no cuz they cuz the boyfriend
moved in but she well yeah any girls
boyfriend moved in and Molly Bernard and
Kelsey felt the need to leave as she
should yeah like she had overstayed her
welcome but she had been saving up all
these years as being an editor at a
publishing house like go get your own
apartment like why do you feel like you
need to go move in with someone or stay
on someone's couch like that is so crazy
to me and that's the only part of like I
feel like the rest of the show is so
authentic to like young New Yorkers
right now yes like the restaurants they
go do like that the clothes they wear
everything except for the fact that like
no one can get an apartment actually I
feel like that's true I feel like I'm
gonna be having to move in with them
pretty soon really yeah I got I think I
might oh my god so wait where is it that
you want to live Cleveland okay so I
think that the tri-state areas Cleveland
is actually Jersey City and I think I
might move there really is that gross no
it's just you just gotta get your like
commute down pat like I know my dream
really like everyday in the city
especially the UN is really pushing me
out um
and every time I like sit in traffic and
I go to box in 40 minutes or even if I
get out and then walk down the street
and get like shoved you know and it's
like hey buddy there's no space there so
there's no space and it's like that
feeling of walking down the street for
some people it's like exhilarating it's
like the sounds the sights the smells in
the beginning and then cut to 12 years
later and you're like enough and for me
it's like just living a quiet life right
would be the drink like I just I would I
know that I would be so much happier but
like right now I love like the toast and
my life here more than I love the
thought of the countryside so that's why
I'm still here but eventually everything
changes
I just could see myself like being
somewhere quiet you're going Cleveland I
think well I thought about it a lot a
lot of all the cities in the country and
like this one's too hot this one's too
cold
blah blah this one's too far if my
family does if everyone sees in New York
like right I don't want to be like the
weird and snitches like living in
California who they can't go visit so
Cleveland like just seems like such a
happy medium and everyone who goes there
like seems have the most positive things
to say about it I have a lot of
listeners in Cleveland and they are
happy sweet nice people it's like when
we went to Minnesota for the Superbowl
everyone was so nice it's so weird how
nice people are outside of New York City
it's so here I even when I went to call
it a thumbs are I mean I could eaten
them don't even get me started on
bathrooms anyways I bring all the women
out there I just want to say this if you
all just sat on the toilet instead of
squatting no one would pee on the seat
yeah like right I'd rather sit where
your butt cheek was then sit on your pee
understand that like that thank you for
coming to my TED talk that is an issue
I'm really passionate like everyone just
sit down the back of your thighs aren't
dirty like really I mean they're really
not they're really not about your pee is
yeah and do you ever find yourself like
cleaning off someone's pee off the seat
and you're like no it's like that MTV
show and it's like freeze-frame like
you're probably fronting you're probably
wondering how I ended up in this
situation because when I see P on the
toilet seat that and I can't like go to
another cell like I wipe it off and then
I put down to the paper and then I also
swap because I need like just in case I
like fall right the case you know I just
it's if somebody has already massacred
the toilet seat I am equally as
disrespectful right but like what if you
accidentally threw your legs give out
like they don't I've got strong thighs
like so it's so hard for me I know the
older I get the more I'm like oh this is
yeah I'm gonna have to start singing on
public toilet seats pretty soon but it
wouldn't be an issue if everyone just
sat down I agree I'm not scared of the
back of your thighs so like don't worry
about it and then you know I'll just be
more comfortable and I think as women we
would get along a lot better
I agree too like I think that Bethenny
and Ramona could get along with and
Carole yeah don't don't tell me you're
team Carole I don't want to talk about
it you're lying I'm sure you ready had
the site with Claudius oh I did I did I
am team
I can see why your team Bethany but I
don't like Bethany from like me her so
right I think I heard it straight teen
anyone but Bethany okay
you know what that's fair okay good so
Carol is like a poor man's Carrie
Bradshaw I'm aware yes yeah it's like
girl stop like a hailing the cab the
season that like her dinner opener with
it like crazy like primary color outfit
on
she looked ridiculous no and like her
we're having coffee that's like so
Carrie Bradshaw
I have taken a leather I that is my
least favorite episode the lover the oh
I mean the Petrovski episodes are the
worst he's disgusting he's horrible no
but I actually okay I feel I feel two
ways about the because watching them the
first time he was like this is horrible
who is this man like this is hard she's
so tiny
but then I rewatched a dork but he also
did bring us you are Comique and that is
just something that has given us that's
great it's so much a joy yes but I
rewatched all of Sex in the City
recently I watch too much TV now that I
think about it and I hate I hate carry
so much like I she said birth I had the
same revelation she's the worst friend
she's a horrible girlfriend with big
it's it's her fault
it's her fault and like big literally
never led her on never made her believe
that relationship was anything other
than it was so when the time comes in
like he doesn't step up like how are you
so surprised talks about church with his
mother embarrassing drops a book
survived the book capital D oh what a
good job no she could so Madison anyway
so then I feel like with the Petroski
episodes she finally like got what she
deserved a little bit like when she
moves to Paris and she's such a loser
and she falls in the door like Thank You
Darren star like she's such a loser in
Paris and like she thought she's like
hot [ __ ] and with all of her like extra
ass outfits and like she's like waiting
for him a museum like good I'm glad
someone just put her through the wringer
a little bit she just needed like a
little taste of that I agree so her that
I think you Alexander Petrovsky um but
yes it was a weird it was a weird time
okay next up Naomi Campbell throw shade
at Kendall Jenner car TV and Nicki Minaj
watch Naomi Campbell has an opinion on
just about everything which makes her
the perfect talk show guest last night
she appeared on Bravo's watch it up and
live with Andy Cohen
where have you were called into asked
what she thought of kendall Jenner being
the hottest highest-paid model
despite insisting she could never do
thirty runway shows in a single season
right he was on that but that was a
really stupid thing for Kendall to say
she should know better just knowing
where she comes from
right cuz she is a real model right like
legit and I feel like the sheet that
that that like that
one statement like threatened all of her
hard work I completely it was just like
she wasn't thinking no or she speaks
Campbell's response next question JLo
who I don't know the exact then the 40
year old 48 year old catwalk Queen was
similarly Shady went in any CO and asked
if she attended the Harper's Bazaar
icons party weeks ago where cardi B
threw her shoe at Nicki Minaj yes
quote no it was called the icon party
but there were no icons there oh she's
such a [ __ ] she said I'm going to say
it because I told Kareem rock right Feld
to her face so I don't think it's
something I can't say she is such a
[ __ ] but also the icon party like it
looks insane and like every year it's so
cool but it does seem like they're
inviting like more pedestrians unusual
not pedestrians but like low-level
talent it's not the Met Gala by and no
no it's not like I feel like the icon
card he's like a little thirsty
you know yeah it's like if you have
millions of social media followers come
even if you're not like the classiest
brought in town and I'm not talking
about car DVR any communal just talking
about like all these Instagram thoughts
who are at the yep on party yep I have
to say I agree
don't forget ever that she threw a cell
phone at her maid I mean who could
forget she's abusive
yeah she's cutthroat then she said her
and Kate Moss were at home on the couch
watching TV during the event I had to
say that but I was disappointed I don't
want to see women of color fight I don't
want to see women fight periods so not
they're not that it's all music there's
no division of music and musics for
everybody there's no discrimination I
felt very disappointed
well said BQ that's amazing totally
that's cute that her and Kate Moss watch
TV together got their place such hungry
[ __ ] together and totally right they
probably don't even
wine you know I definitely not calories
they probably put tampons of vodka up
their butts oh my god that's hilarious
that's a thing that's a real thing I've
heard about it or up the Machine I
haven't tried it
oh that was my next question I'm sure I
believe it to be a real thing yeah it's
kind of smart because people really do
anything to like be drunk but it's also
like we've made alcohol as good as it
could possibly be but the end of the day
like vodka is nail polish remover like
it's horrible I actually like it up for
me gin is like well actually that's not
true
cuz I actually had this deal that I do
my social media with gin and I was like
really worried cuz I was like is this
gonna be so bad like rubbing alcohol and
it was actually pretty good really if
you mix if you mix like alcohol spirits
with like anything good enough it's
gonna be good yeah a mixed drink for
sure but not its core like vodka even
though you know Grey Goose Tito's
they've done a great job on the rocks
you know filling it ya know
vodka a shot of vodka is not a delicious
delicacy no it's not as all as I'm
saying so if you can get drunk by
putting a tampon up your bum why not
it's not the craziest thing okay next
story uh Jourdan and Jojo Fletcher okay
I'm making the press rounds this week
they posted on Instagram that they are
having a TV show unclear if it's on TV
the net with the like company behind it
I don't know where you can even watch it
it was weird but I think we all assumed
they were filming a TV show based on
like their Instagram stories and they're
always like renovating homes and stuff
looks like they wanted a HD TV show but
instead they got like a kinetic show or
whatever network fake Network it's on
right I still haven't figured it out but
they spoke to page six and here's why
Jordan Rogers and Jojo Fletcher are
waiting to Wed but we don't have any
wedding plans yet but I think getting
settled into a new place will be a big
first step Rogers told page six Tuesday
of the pair's move to Dallas they've
been living in Dallas for years though
really yeah like ever since the show
ended
she's from there they just like new hire
moving together for um coming up like so
now to two years and they still haven't
got married no and it doesn't even seem
like they set a date quote we've been
traveling a ton and what I
always tell people to is when you finish
the show it's an interesting period of
time because you're merging your lives
together figuring out where you're going
to live so really the first year and
year and a half it's gone and you're
still dating someone so we enjoy that
and ask and that aspect of being engaged
and appreciating every aspect of our
life the SEC network analyst continued
that I understand I feel like after even
though they're engaged after the show
they're dating yeah and it's like a year
where you're figuring out if this is the
right person for you yes and then a year
where you're actually engaged yes but
then it's time so I actually I'm like
turning to like such a disappointing it
dude in this regard but it's like when
it comes to like sotae and I have been
together now for like three years three
and a half years and you know I mean we
talked about getting engaged to get
married but I'm like for the first year
of our relationship it was kind of like
I was like readjusting the fact that I
was taking a girl which I never foresaw
my future and like being a gay person
and so that for me was like very like
the struggle was real like I was like I
like so I'm like can we deduct a year
from our relationship in terms of
expectation of me proposing to you
totally cuz like I feel like for that
first year I was just like I was like a
teenager rediscovering like who I was
again so that like doesn't count
like I feel about people who start
dating in college it's like even though
it's a dated three years in college once
you move and once you graduate and say
you're moving you move to the same city
and almost like these sets because it's
a whole different relationship every
relationships that work in college are a
lot of times like it's just so easy yeah
and then in the real world it's not so
if you make like the first year of
dating in post graduation like is really
the first year exactly
and those three years before like no
offense don't count right right it's
just like could you can judge at frat
parties and then like go into class and
that's not like that's a real it's not
you don't have a it don't you like live
in a bubble totally yep that's what
college is the best yeah where'd you go
to college if the car only went to
Colgate upstate New York smart school I
went to I got rejected from all the
smart schools
where'd you apply oh my god everywhere
my early my mom maybe my mom made me
apply to McGill because it was the
Harvard of Canada no we knew I couldn't
get into Harvard so it's like we tried
to backdoor it anyway Amherst College
which was like the Harvard of like
Massachusetts yep if god what else
u.s. younger
in Massachusetts can't get couldn't get
in could again be see you need a whiner
and why you you know how many rejection
letters I got a lot a lot even Union
rejected me oh my god I almost went to
Union but their colors are brown and
white and that's just wasn't I'm quite
like it looks like the the logo just
looks much like onion like I I didn't
know I wanted to go to like a liberal
arts school I was just like I want a big
school features shrunken down to a small
size so my kind is kind of got my
college guidance counselor recommended
Union Skidmore and I'm just like
skidmarks know if you're not going to
skip Network even though like one of my
good friends just went there it should
be well it's a great day I mean it's
skidmark right and all I was doing was
judging colleges books by their cover
like Goucher I was like Gauchos have
been out for so long I can't go there
and I'm like Colgate I really couldn't
find a problem with and it was like
definitely reach for me I always wanted
to apply early to a reach school because
I don't use your early decision on a
schooling you can get into if I didn't
find a school I wanted to go to early
decision I would have applied early to
Harvard and like made the best case for
myself just like you just like out like
you know if you just grades aside I
can't remember cloudy night litter they
had this exact conversation I can't
remember if it was here or on the
patreon I think it was patron so it's
just I love talking about the college
process I know it's so it says so much
about like your family dynamics like
everything uh-huh and it's like what you
really want for yourself because I feel
like me choosing to go to Colgate like
says so much about me that I didn't even
really realize it was like I just want
to go I want to leave the city please
yes Cleveland and I just want to go
somewhere like pretty and it was it is
the most beautiful school it was the
country best time of your life it was
the best friend that's college is the
best it is it really is but there was
like the course like the schoolwork and
the homework because there wasn't much
going on in the town like you didn't
have you couldn't get an internship it's
like no it was the same it was like a
total college town right so and I think
the professor's like they want you to
have to be as busy with like real stuff
as possible and not just like drinking
and like blacking out so there was so
much school where I majored in that no I
had like so little school
oh my god I had so much school working
like that part
like really punk was really hard for me
do you still have nightmares about home
and school and I have a paper due or
like your like I didn't know I had this
class all semester I haven't gone oh my
god yes oh man I'm like I have done any
of the homework assignment no I I
literally so scared and it's like I
forgot to drop it so now like I didn't
go to W I had this dream all the time I
wonder what it means we should like
dream book it
we should have a well I feel two ways
about dreams because they are pretty
interesting but I hate when other people
like tell me they're just like I had a
dream last night I was riding a unicorn
through the forest and then you were
there like actually wait I was there
great tell me more about it
what was I wearing I had a friend that
was mad at me for like a month because
she had a dream she had a dream I was
having an orgy with her boyfriend and
some other dude we know I like that I
was no that's crazy I was insulted I
would never have an orgy I was having
like stress dreams about like the show
today because it was like everything was
last minute and oh I know and in my
dream last night it was I was having
Vanessa Grimaldi on today okay who is
from The Bachelor who was engaged to
Nick vile
and I mean it was like really stressing
me out and then like I couldn't find the
podcast equipment it was just like
really bad anyways I was glad to wake up
and remember it was you it was really
and I was like back at kholby and they
were doing all this construction and I
couldn't find my way around Oh stress
yeah school stress yep maybe it means
something it's a tablet into everything
or it really means nothing or no it's
just your brain go it's like a last
thing you watch on television
totally which was what did I watch last
night something terribly trashing oh no
shits Creek not trash whatsoever I got
to watch that huh you have to you would
like it it's the real deal I'll watch it
and it's so funny anyway so George and
Jojo are not planning a wedding yet but
I feel like they're they're ready and
they really are like they really hit the
ground running in terms of like they
moved exactly to the same city a lot of
bachelor couples they have to figure out
where they're gonna live then if someone
moves to somewhere out someone else's
town that's cute that's a huge
adjustment he has like a very real job
he's an SEC network I don't like sports
analysts for college football okay and
his brothers Aaron Rodgers so like that
seems to work really well my god okay
it's this one it's this one it was he
like the worst or was he the best on his
season at first when I started watching
the season I was like
it's the two of them 100% like he's out
of everybody's league and and they know
it and we know it or whatever and then
when they actually wound up like getting
engaged it was like it seemed like weird
and fake and there were all these like
rumors that they weren't doing well and
when they went on after the final rose I
was like oh this is so [ __ ] fake but
the proof is in the pudding and they've
like they moved to Dallas immediately
like they didn't move to LA which is
like just about like the thirstiest
Vegas thing you could do in a
relationship yes after you're on The
Bachelor right and they live like a very
quiet life because like when I go to
Dallas and I'd like friends there who
are friends with or were friends with
them but they like just now really are
only with each other they like remodel
homes and stuff and it seems like a very
nice like legitimate life that they've
made for themselves her family's in
Dallas so it's like I love Dallas
because I watch - do we have to talk I
know let's just talk about it because
okay our fifth and final story can wait
um I'm just I'm so here like it's so
hard to be a new franchise and really
like make a name for your so hardened I
was really like I was anti I was I was
kicking and screaming but when I was
doing getting younger
so Priscilla does my makeup or did my
makeup for on getting younger and she
does like all the housewives I met her
through Stassi and so she said to me
would you mind if Brandi comes against
her makeup done cuz she's doing like a
pre record for watch what happens live
like I don't have anywhere to go in the
city and I was like of course you can
come here like I'm Viacom space let her
own it so brandi was in there getting
her makeup done and I had not watched
one episode of Dallas so I had like no
opinion on her and I she was like very
soft-spoken and sweet and like I've kind
of feel like she thought that I should
probably know about her and also her and
Stassi you're like kind of like
Instagram friendly
yeah and Stephanie yes yes so I don't
know I like Torah knew Stassi whatever
and she was like sweet enough so I went
and I watch because I knew like Stassi
loved it too and I was like I hate this
this is the worst season Stephanie and
Brandi are so annoying
I cannot stand them like I was like such
a hater and then I just hunker down and
like go through season one and it is so
epic and everything I'm so happy I
committed to it season two is so good
and you know if you're not a patient
person just start with season two
because you can because yeah you could
you you could and you know they'll
probably explain enough and like season
two we get like two new cast members
anyway grow ever lose
Serban and his girlfriend Tiffany
bye-bye except that song that he
performed for Brandis brother um he's
really good made you cry I know I just
like then added it to my iTunes and it's
like part of not my Spotify and it's
just like part of my daily listening
regimen for a while um no so right now
just it's in a really good place also
the best thing that they could have done
was put it on during the same like
season as OC yes which is going down the
tubes you think yes I love Kelly dog God
Kelly died yeah she called that little
dork a dork I nearly died I nearly
passed out I had to keep going back and
we're winding and pausing and watching
it cuz he is such he's like a Napoleon
man complex like toad like through and
through what's her name the new one well
it's confusing because Emily looks like
Gina and Gina looks like an Emily
totally totally yeah but Emily's husband
is just like I cannot stand him he's a
judgmental little [ __ ] I was holding out
my judgment for him just cuz I thought
maybe he was like putting just a couple
of unfortunate situations but then when
Kelly came over and apologized and he
was still being a little [ __ ] yeah like
she was really humbling herself she
brought her daughter over like she's
stroking your dog like let it go man not
everything has to be a joke that really
bothers me when Pete like I understand
sarcasm Belleza I was like sucker I I
think he's dead dead ass I don't think
he's suck has to get all I think that's
her excuse for his behavior
yeah even if it's an it's not an even if
it's your excuse like it's not a worthy
excuse like sometimes like you just have
to like say thank you you apologize and
you move on I know right yeah I'm glad
that didn't sit well he's a little [ __ ]
but he's all the things she said yeah
well when she's called me at work like
that was kind of funny and light and
almost like an estate like it's such an
innocent term to use it was like so
genuine because she was like you're a
dork yeah but then she started saying
other mean things like little [ __ ] and
stuff right Dorothy
Dork was kind of like funny and like a
funny way to talk [ __ ] about someone but
then like she she went in which is the
Kelly dad way and we wouldn't expect any
I think she is so she's so great I'll
watch just for her same with fashions so
like the beauty like the attitude just
like the the red lip oh yes I think
she's a boobs
perfect
and I love her attitude her spirit and
like her newly single like she wanted
Eve yes Dallas but Dallas so anyways
Dallas coming on the heels of OC I think
was a good thing like his last season of
OC was it was not very good um so where
do you stand likely and DeAndre Leandre
okay so I Jaya a little bit behind so
I'm on the episode where they were at
Beaver Creek okay it's a Beaver Creek
yeah and they were at the dinner and
they were doing the pageant stupid stuff
and and DeAndre was like bringing up
Leigh Ann's like the marriage like
what's going on something's going on and
I kind of felt like so are they in a
fight now yeah but it's like they they
bicker and then they make up and it
seems like something really big is
brewing also like Leon came on the show
and was like talking mad smack about the
Andrea know and then LeAnn yes she said
she was gonna like dress up as a $200
super Halloween and to be dancers bank
account you'll get there soon and then D
and Renly and we're both on macho
diamonds live still talking [ __ ] like
about each other so it's not result it's
definitely a big problem that makes me
sad cuz they were like legit friends
yeah and they like they were brandy it's
it's it's brandy right that's why that's
why Leon's at least like having a prom
with Deandra at least right now she's
like blaming and I'm brandy but I don't
think it's raining I think that Sandra
just like she's I don't know how old she
is but like she's done pretty like just
putting on I feel like being on this
show has made her realize they people
love her the way that she is last season
she was a hundred percent a fan favorite
yeah I loved her and like when she spoke
her mind like she was really always on
the right side of history and I feel
like that gave her so much confidence to
not have to be like this Dallas
socialite like I'm gonna put my cake up
up my butt and it's hilarious I'm gonna
be who I want to be today which is the
validation of America where it's like
Dallas society might not like it right
but she doesn't care anymore and I love
that and also she's like I mean I know
it's like her mom's money whatever but
she is like so wealthy but she do
whatever she really wants to do and I
like that I think she's genuine so but
in a few episodes like it comes out like
yes her family's wealthy but like her
mom controls everything and she really
doesn't have that much money do you did
she go shopping in Beavercreek yet yes
ah like four thousand something dollars
right and then they couldn't spend
another two thousand yes and then
apparently she came home that night and
told the N like she only has two hundred
dollars in her bank account but then it
turns out she has multiple bank accounts
but that's just her shopping bank
account also she might have like put
that four thousand dollars on her mom's
business card
which it's like the IRS better not be
like okay so whose team are you on
I think I'm gonna still be Deandra um I
do like I love I love that Leanne's on
the show I don't know how I feel about
Leanne I know his hands
I love Leanne as a person and like the
last time she the first time she came on
the show like everything I thought about
her immediately that completely changed
like I just loved her I think she's such
an actually good person and she's a
Nicole and a good TV character like oh
yeah oh yeah it's hard to toe the line
of being like interesting yes and nice
yes I don't know that I would use the
word nice to describe no but like she
does try and be a good friend so I love
Christmas in then Leanne mercy and your
fight right now I don't really know
exactly where I stand I feel like
there's more that we don't know like I
feel like something happened between
them that's making them take cheap shots
at each other I think it wasn't nice
though like when someone's your best
friend in front of a bunch of women that
you know she's uncomfortable around cuz
she wasn't drinking that weekend to like
put her on the spot about her marriage
and be like there's something more than
I'll just bottle I'll let it go for now
that's kind of a mean girl thing to do I
totally agree and even if there is some
like first of all they've been engaged
for a year so it's not like that crazy
that they haven't set a date it's
actually considering that they dated for
so long like what makes you think
they're gonna like hop to it now I know
like what rush are they so at their
anniversary party like saying you're a
gay marriage like that was Bob that was
weird it's like she's like kind of muses
her as the butt of the joke yeah and I
feel like being her friend and like
knowing what she's been through with the
show in the cast means she should be
like I have a little bit more of like a
sensitivity when it comes to that yeah
like be friends with Brandi fine but
like that was like don't humiliate
LeeAnn in front of the other girls
because she's definitely insecure yeah
and just and has every right to be right
and if something's going on like my tea
you need to be the one to like bring it
to the surface yeah I mean like a real
friend that would be like a not
on-camera conversation yeah and it seems
like next week's episode
they can't injure confronts LeAnn again
about her relationship and like accuse
and like in Sydney we've got here some
English that rich is like having affairs
not good for it so then I'm gonna have
to end up being Tim Lam probably yeah I
do like D'Andra but yeah it's but I like
not knowing who said I like it being a
little ambiguous not so like cut and dry
like everyone hates this person and then
it's like I want them off the show but
then it's like
them Danielle Staub season 1 that is not
a show make no it does not
Cameron I I don't know I'm really I've
like literally until last night the
episode that I watch I hated her like I
was like I hate you
I hate everything you stand for she's
like such a little prissy [ __ ] and I'm
like stuff like like I'm fun you're not
fun you're the opposite of fun and even
she said when she was little
she was like the fun killer yeah so I'm
not a huge fan of hers and she's like so
sensitive and like and she also she is
ditzy I know she like pretends like
she's not but she keeps saying like
she's like so smart and you know once
you know like once you you think you
underestimate her and then she comes
through and it's like it's been a season
and a half now and I haven't seen that
side of you so like when what what was
it was like blondes get noticed smart
blonds get everything but her face is
just so I mean she's beautiful regarde
like and she's like yeah and his body
and like she's like she's very like
statuesque but like she's weird right
yeah I know she's like she's just like
out she's like a little Muppet baby no
totally but it's like I think it's like
her personality it causes her to be that
way it's not a physical thing no it's a
IIIi think I find her personality so
off-putting that she's becoming
unattractive to me
right but that pink number she's wearing
the season I die for it like I like what
is that no sane and I do I'm like her
husband's like obviously she marry him
he's rich and like like not supporting
them smart and then the sparkle dog of
Dolly he doesn't love her he thinks
she's so annoying Cuddy and I think like
he put her on the show so that he could
divorce her kelsey grammer style Jerry
O'Connell disagrees he does yeah he was
like no I just think that Court is like
from it like another like he doesn't
know how to just like support his wife
yet
okay and like know there is a learning
curve on the show yeah but I mean she
drives me absolutely nuts but I don't
know I saw a side to her that I kind of
liked in this Beavercreek episode I
don't know maybe I just liked her house
I agree and it also seen her house and
like understanding really more about
like courts family and like the insanity
helped a little to understand why she's
so nuts
yeah not fully and then the baby bashing
and it was just she was so confused yeah
she just is so self-righteous and I
can't stand people like that but she's
so pretty
I'd like you know I kind of just like
want to be her
I'm for example a jury's still out
sherry still out and also the last week
she was having a conversation with
Stephanie and I don't think that they
get along where they don't like knocking
along but I feel like there's something
brewing there and what I've realized is
I feel like Stephanie is everything like
Camryn wishes she could be I love
Stephanie because Stephanie is classy
like her home is beautiful so like you
know her husband does well but she
represents him so well while still
having fun it's like Cameron wants to be
all of those things and can't figure it
out yeah she can't be real you know true
self and Stephanie can and I love and
now cut to what season three I love
Brandi and Stephanie so much I'm
obsessed with I'm Brandi and her baby
boy like sweet so how do you feel about
Carrie I don't like her do you
I think she's I think I think that they
did have an affair for sure but I feel
like it's like lalala and Randall like
yes it started in an attainted way but
this they don't own it ya know and it's
like they what's the term house
what home wrecker home right it's like
they wrecked the home but then they
built a new home right you know
sometimes it's got to happen sometimes
the ugly house on the street has to come
down but it's like the way that the
march on Jersey like came and be like
yep I cheated on my husband and this is
the guy who treated with an Marge it's
just like just like lay it all out there
I like that I think that's the way you
do housewives it's like yeah
biggie gaga style yeah you just like
drop your balls in the table and you're
like this is me and now you can't get
anything on me because it's all out in
the open
yeah and I feel like the ones that are
like and I feel like okay I think Harry
is not being totally honest okay I
really came on the show was she here and
I loved her I just said she was like
just so real down-to-earth like a real
person my husband I think doesn't like
their kid oh yeah that that was that was
really weird last season but I think
like the two of them are a great match
you know totally like there is a lid for
every pot totally and they are each
other's yep yep that's fair
you know Mikey I would like he's not my
type of guy but I'm not hurt right so I
would love to meet her hopefully I get
to meet her I feel like it would change
her mind uh-oh I always change my mind a
D always changes my mind always it's so
hard and then because I know if have you
ever interviewed somebody
like you thought you were gonna like
come for and then you just like you've
really still hated them afterwards I
really feel hated them afterwards
honestly no and there have been so many
like not so many but there's a few like
instances that come to top of mind
immediately of people that like I wasn't
agreeing with their behavior on the show
and then meeting them made me see
everything completely differently I know
Margaret Joseph's yeah I know of her I
loved her
I just interviewer the other day and I'm
like she is I want to be her best friend
like legit legit well I was gonna
destroy Stassi when she came on my show
when I was at Sirius all those years ago
it was less season one Stassi loved
season ones I was always Team Stassi
even if Jax didn't get that girl
pregnant it was like why are we your
friends not take your side when you're
and yes now that I know I'm like totally
but in the moment watching sure you're
minding it like every mean girl I ever
met my entire life and so I was like I'm
gonna put her in her place and then I
met her and she was like I love your
show and I was like oh [ __ ] well now I
love you back and now all the rest is
history history but I feel like yeah
very rarely do I ever after meeting them
dislike them and even if I did going in
yeah it's hard not to know people
totally they're people yep okay fifth
story and then we'll get back into Bravo
and just life um but facial recognition
could revolutionize public
transportation Wow I'm kind of here for
this but then there's no text in the
article CNNMoney and I was not watching
your video okay so I guess we have to
glean from that what we Phil but I guess
it's like instead of a metro card I
don't know if that's like very clear TSA
the iPhone right I mean it's like how
you get into your iPhone yeah but it's
like then again it's 23andme it's like
you have all this information on me I
know and you know I haven't committed a
crime yet so you don't you don't deserve
it
yeah you don't deserve my fingerprints
do you use that clear thing on TS at the
airport I'm not clear but I was um what
was the one that was before it yes a
pre-check you got it well then there was
the other thing though um Global Entry
oh so I signed up to Global Entry but it
expired I realized that standing in line
coming back from can I was like kill me
okay um it was it was like the worst day
ever when I came back from can and I my
global answer didn't work I couldn't cut
the line
[Laughter]
I am oh my god um but I haven't done
clear but my girlfriend has clear and
she like dies for it it's really amazing
because she travels so much for work
though
well that's the thing every time I
travel I'm like oh I should do PSA
pre-checker Global Entry and it's like I
leave the country once a year I can
stand on this line as opposed to going
down to City Hall I know I'm having to
stand on that line I don't know I think
I'll do clear I'll do it but then once
everyone's on clear isn't it the same -
today and it's also funny when the when
the regular line is shorter than TSA
projects like Oh
drives me nuts I know if you wait long
enough you know being obsolete is the
way to go
totally but I feel like they like Metro
cards and facial recognition like I
don't think that that's the problem with
public transportation
ah no it's all the construction on the
weekends like there's my face fix app
because if it doesn't then I don't need
it and it's like AC please you're gonna
be so hard right god yeah so ah no I
don't need that no it sounds cool though
yeah except like my like yellow metro
card it's will suffice like that's not
my problem I like my MetroCard it works
just fine
except like when you take the bus how do
you fill up your MetroCard girl I refuse
to the bus I would go I would rather
take the bus in the subway nope opposite
subway I love the subway oh my god the
subway gives me such anxiety like I
traffic as me anxiety I cannot I hate
the buses there are names no but they
still sit in traffic but it's that's
just unnecessary even if I'm in an uber
I'm gonna sit in traffic plus like in
the winter you're like outside waiting
for the boss no ma'am I was down on the
ground
but like the subway what about when it
gets stuck like it doesn't you don't
know when it's gonna get unstuck I know
I have a good claustrophobic I don't I'm
not like diagnosed classed you're phobic
but like I used to take the subway all
the time like to work and stuff and then
just one too many times it got stuck on
the ground sometimes it's for a minute
yeah sometimes it's for 20 minutes yeah
and it's like you don't know why it's
stuck like you just have to have all
this blind trust in the conductor in
this train that you don't know how it
works I mean you're your fellow transfer
fellow commuters yes yeah and we feel
like it's I feel that same way when I
take a plane it's like I don't know how
this thing works and I have to trust
everyone that I'm on this plane without
to trust the pilot and there is that
sense of anxiety but I only get on a
plane like maybe once a month
whereas like if I'm taking the subway
multiple times okay I can't live with
that feeling and then I show up
everywhere like [ __ ] Betty Cooper
nails in my palms like angry ready to
punch someone who's gonna stick a hand
up my skirt yeah hey fine Farrah but I
love the subway I just had I know so
like I am just I look like ready like
just come beat me up you know I know I
know well and also when I used to have
my engagement ring I used to flip it
over on the subway oh that's smart it
would make me nervous but ya know but
like I just look like so [ __ ]
helpless oh yeah and I am so it's like
and correct you would be right and like
I you sitting in high school I would
take the subway and just it was like
there's always so many not so many but
there's always one crazy person that's
just gets in your face I remember one
time I was on the subway and I was in
high school and a crazy man started
yelling in my face and I just like
didn't look at him like yeah I just
stood there okay you can't like look
them in the eye and not one person on
the subway like came to mind if I said
that that's the fucked-up part it's
definitely bad it's bad I know cuz
sometimes like will someone help me if
something goes down right now and the
answer is absolutely no no and it's like
I think I'm defenseless now and I like
require someone to come and help me like
I was ten years younger like smaller and
sadder with my little backpack you know
I mean who actually was a big backpack
on a little person and it's like you're
not gonna help that person [ __ ] you guys
I'm out of here I'm contributing to the
pollution in an uber that's fair that's
fair that's so Fiamma tais yeah you just
like one actually I've had multiple bad
experiences and it's like that one that
just breaks the camel's back and it's
like I'm not getting back on yep fair
enough fair enough I won't push you to
ride the subway no and it's yeah so I
either uber or if traffic's really bad I
just want like to walk places now it's
sad too
except now the streets are so congested
with the UN I know girl tell me about it
anyways facial recognition though I
don't even have it on my phone
also I'm me they're pulling up all the
questions that we have for you and that
one question that really stuck out to me
that I thought was such a person in
question they want to know how you deal
with it is when you talk about [ __ ]
about people on your show
and then there also people in your life
right so oh I think what I tend to do is
I talk the ship before I get to know the
people for example like all Amanda Kyle
right so I'm just a really good
apologizer at this point and like I'm so
aware that like my job and you get this
- it's like to kind of be like like very
very opinionated and like knee-jerk
reactive and talk a lot of [ __ ] but as
quickly like as bold as my statements
are I'm so quick to change my mind so
like give me the opportunity and I'll
take your mind in two seconds totally so
I'm kind of like sorry but you kind of
seem like a dick on the show but now I
met you and you're not a dick sorry I
was a dick what about when you have
friendships with like - like people on
the same show who don't get along I mean
which I'm sure says a lot but I don't
yeah I mean I I I could have been in
that position are you following me I
think I know you might be yeah but that
person decided to like for other reasons
like not engage with me anymore
so that person did the choosing for me
got which made things a lot honestly a
lot easier yes I was thinking the other
day I'm having Kyle and Amanda on my new
podcast so I'm like I'm my podcast ace
of Taylor I'm relaunching next Wednesday
exciting and Jerry O'Connell is on it
he's my first one and then I have the
March and then I'm gonna have Kyle and
Amanda and so I was thinking if I were
still friends with somebody that would
probably be I probably wouldn't able to
have Kyle and Amanda on because I am
like very loyal and so and I don't upset
my friends right but like it's tricky
because in this business like when
people are on the same show and you're
friends of all of them and then they
have like a fight it's like you have to
be really careful like how you conduct
like your relations before because it's
friendship but it's also business right
and that's frustrating anything it's
like it's friendship and it's loyalty
but if your friend like can't respect
that you are right like this is your job
and like so you can separate the two but
they can't like that's also frustrating
exactly exactly so like for example
Priscilla was saying how she was so
Priscilla co-host with me on my radio
show it's confusing
the other day so many shows so never
it's
it's a disease I scare myself like my
girlfriend like do you ever stop I'm
like no never
so Priscilla was on the show and she was
talking so she does like all the hair
and makeup for all the braava liberties
and she said on the show that she
actually was doing Sheena's makeup in
the beginning and stassi's people reach
out to her after she was alive she knit
was on watch what happens live to do
stossel's make it and she said no
because she knew she was having a
problem with her and she felt like she
had to be a loyal but then she didn't
Stasi made up and so then she started to
that's how I thought per Silvester Stasi
and so I was like how did you get into
this whole thing and she told me the
story but she said that once they made
up and then she started doing Stasi and
then they fell out again then she said
Sheena I know no now I'm not going back
in the fourth that is too much no kind
of her to even like say no nastasi why
you weren't getting along like it's a
job I said to her I was like oh my god
you're so loyal I'm so impressed but
she's like that's when she says but she
said this was like the beginning stages
of working on Bravo and she's like now I
go she's like girl I have no time for
that right she cuz she does everyone
yeah and she's like I cannot be getting
into their drama because like show like
she did Teresa and also doesn't Alyssa
yeah so I mean but like I feel like so
what Priscilla does is what I do I'm
gonna start to do that which is it's
like sorry ginger ch state this is
business if there's someone that they're
worth talking to have them on exactly
someone asked Kyle and Amanda do you
think they're gonna make it so because
I'm divorced
of course like I'm jaded when it comes
to marriage but do you know that the
divorce rate has gone down as we
reported yesterday solve that yet
encouraging stuff it is it is thank you
Millennials you're welcome you're the
reason but I will say this if I was
going based off of the show I would say
no they're not gonna make it but based
off of watching them like IRL on stone
street drunk all of us together that
night they were adorable together and
they make so much sense and they're
really really cute so yes they're really
cute and they came on the show a while
back and they were so cute and I wasn't
all caught up on summer house I don't
know what they drama is like then or was
between them they fight a lot but
they're drinking I mean same same right
and like you're also on TV so there's
like this like pressure but like
expectation that ain't like a happy
couple just dilly-dallying like isn't
that interesting to watch that would be
fake to like throw a couple real couples
fight totally agree yeah if you had to
describe yourself in one song lyric or
movie quote what would you choose one
song lyric or movie quote what would I
choose oh I know this is what my movie
quote would be it's just one word I
[ __ ] love that see I took the LSAT
because of Legally Blonde and I did
terrible you didn't get it 179 179 no I
didn't but me apparently that's not a
real score you can get really yeah
that's what Olivia told me that's really
that's crazy cuz that was a score I was
aiming for what did you get oh my god
girl like pretty low like I knew if I
couldn't get into like even semi-decent
law schools I wasn't gonna even bother
applying I was gonna retake and I like
look my options and they were so so you
pivoted yeah now you're doing very
similar arguing cases left and right you
got a Carol V bet I'm like a trial
lawyer every single day no it's got
important stuff I was like Bravo
legitimacy do you watch watch a times
I've know it cuz it's late and I don't
know I mean I don't watch any late-night
talk shows though so if there's any
other collection of him it's funny I
don't consider like I don't think I
guess cuz I record it's always in my
queue if I'm like looking for something
to watch and I'll see who the guests are
I was watching Deandra last night with
Tom Arnold and oh my god he was like the
worst guest ever and now I almost like
feel bad saying it because it was almost
as if like something wasn't right
really they like felt bad for Deandra
and for Annie like you couldn't ask him
a question without like just him taking
so long to answer and then not giving an
answer oh it was like it was really
painful that's the word but then I
watched Chrissy Teigen and Kelly Dodd
and it was amazing yeah they were really
cute together you know I just watched a
play by our Bravo's play by play and I
loved it but and I'm like I will go back
and watch like the next one the next but
like I don't know why I don't watch
watch what happens live it's the
weirdest thing because I mean and when
it's weekly it's easy it's more
manageable then yeah then then daily and
daily maybe that's why I don't but it's
so friggin short yeah that could also be
a jealousy thing again I could just be
that jealous of Andy Cohen
that I can't bring myself to watch him
live my dreams he
no he's totally living the dream and
it's like it's a long dream you know
it's been going like yeah once upon a
time he was like sitting Carrie Bradshaw
for shoes at Barneys and now he's
sitting down with Chrissy Teigen how do
you feel about her
I love her love her she had her I have
not but I have a friend who was at a
party with her she had her period so my
friend had a yeah she hired a period I
love her she's my friend had a white
pony like clutch and she put it down
like this like like modern couch so it
was like like a flat arm and Chrissy
came over and like sat down on it and so
she was also like it's like kind of
sitting on my friend's purse whatever
and when she got up she had Pirie
blooded on my friends purse and she
immediately grabbed my friend of mine oh
my god doesn't know my friend oh my god
I guess period blood it all over your
bag I'll buy her a new one I'm like that
[ __ ] is real I love her Wow
that made me like her a lot more because
she's just like I would be so
embarrassed like I would like steals oh
my god I would like either I would throw
their purse in the child if no one saw I
would just walk away leave the party no
one would know it was me
mortifying and she's like oh my god it's
my period blood girl I think that is so
her though right totally you know well I
have I do have a new respect I'm not
gonna lie and I do love how much she
like loves Bravo like it's familiar with
the catalogue yep she really should go
on housewives I wonder why she doesn't
like she I'm sure she could if she
wanted to I think she likes to be an
observer you know she doesn't have to
get in the nitty-gritty it's like it's a
good guilty pleasure right that's Bravo
I'm not I don't feel guilty any I don't
like because it's my job I'm so like
when I act like sometimes we'll ugly be
at a late dinner it's like I have to go
home and like watch Real Housewives and
like I have homework to do I know and I
don't feel like I'm like oh I have to go
watch TV and like be an [ __ ] it's
like no I need to go I'm going to do my
work I need to go do my work I bring my
work home with me I'm just I'm never not
working I just can't help myself look at
the world we've created for ourselves no
it's not a justification of like all the
bad habits we have totally it's amazing
actually but then it's like I don't I
wouldn't watch so much TV if I didn't
have to do this every day I definitely
wouldn't watch The Bachelor anymore but
that I feel like required to just so I
can like speak on it if something crazy
does happen I feel
I actually should start watching The
Bachelor but I just can't do it
no I'm so far behind I'll never catch up
and like now if anything just watch
bachelor I'm paradise it's like urine
and quicker but the bachelor it's like
they they don't know what to do they
don't know how to matter it's crazy it's
crazy but I'd like to know everything
from the beginning so I can like for my
own creek under 10% like if I'm starting
a show I'm starting from season one yeah
I need to know the history yes because
you can't know your future if you don't
understand the past thank you okay I
feel like that's a great note to end on
thank you for coming and doing this with
me on such short notice I'm so sorry we
were late thank you to the state trooper
who did not give us a ticket very kind
of you
and I hope you all enjoyed we will see
you back here tomorrow Friday whoo with
Claudia she will be back good back from
the nation's capital they're exciting
can't wait to hear about it and yeah
thanks for tuning in we will see you
tomorrow